no one expected the final trailer for
the Harry Potter prequel fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald to tell
them anything they didn't already know
from watching previously released
teasers and TV spots but when Warner
Brothers dropped the last piece of
promotional footage on September 25th
minds were blown why because it features
a brief clip of a woman named Nagini
turning into a snake and that has opened
a huge can of worms for Harry Potter
fans leading Harry Potter author JK
Rowling to issue a public defence of the
film in the original Harry Potter series
Nagini was a gigantic sinister snake who
served as the evil Lord Voldemort's
companion and assistant while also
acting as a Horcrux one of the vessels
for a portion of Voldemort's soul Nagini
was eventually slain by Neville
Longbottom opening the way for
Voldemort's final defeat so the
revolution that Nagini was once a human
woman that can turn into a snake or
possibly a snake that turns into a woman
is definitely a shocker for fans but the
surprise hasn't been all that welcomed
by everyone both longtime and casual
fans of the franchise have a number of
concerns perhaps most importantly over
the choice to cast south korean actress
and Marvel Universe veteran Claudia Kim
in the role Twitter user Jen Moulton
started the firestorm when she tagged
ruling in a tweet that read in part
listen we get it you didn't include
enough representation when you wrote the
books but suddenly making Nagini into a
Korean woman is garbage representation
as an afterthought for more woke points
is not good representation other Twitter
users piled on with one decrying the
decision to cast one of the two actors
of color in the fantastic beasts
franchise as a quote literal object
owned by a white man inspired by Nazis
and others voiced concerns that the
casting choice for echoes of old
stereotypes such as those associating
Asian people with snakes as well as the
dragon lady cliche Rowling didn't take
the criticism lying down responding to
the original attack with a tweet that
said the Nagas are snake-like mythical
creatures of Indonesian mythology hence
the name Nagini they are sometimes
depicted as winged sometimes as half
human half snake Indonesia comprises a
few hundred ethnic groups including
Javanese Chinese and bateau we have a
lovely day
she later added that she has been
holding on to the secret of Nagini
true nature for around 20 years that
revelation seemed to actually spark even
more anger from another subsection of
fans who complain about Rowling's
history of revealing or changing details
of the Harry Potter universe years after
the series wrapped up most famously
three months after the final book came
out in 2007 she announced that
Dumbledore was gay and had been in love
with Grindelwald many applauded Rowling
for the announcement but some felt she
was trying to have her cake and eat it
too by pandering to LGBTQ fans without
truly taking the perceived risk of
actually portraying Dumbledore as gay in
either the books or films the Dumbledore
controversy gained new energy in January
2018 when director David Yates revealed
that fantastic beasts the crimes of grin
devolve won't make it explicitly clear
the Dumbledore played by Jude Law is gay
despite the purported love of his life
being at the center of the sequel story
instead there seemed to be just vague
hints for hardcore Harry Potter fans to
decipher Dumbledore
why can't you guys I cannot know the
guys crinkles
it has to be here the Nagini and
Dumbledore controversies are just the
latest PR hits for fantastic peace the
crimes of Grindelwald which has faced
intense scrutiny from the moment it was
revealed in November 2017 that Johnny
Depp was set to return to the role of
Grindelwald from 2016 s fantastic beasts
and where to find them
despite highly publicized allegations
that he had assaulted his ex-wife Amber
Heard prior to their divorce it remains
to be seen whether any of these
controversies will affect how fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald
performs at the box office when it
arrives in theatres on November 16th
2018 but one thing is for sure even if
the film isn't a must watch for everyone
JK Rowling's Twitter feed definitely is
[Music]